i lost my virginity on 9 11.
the real 9 11 2001 is the first time i
had sex with a woman
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know you're about to do it what's up
everybody i'm christos stefano here to
answer the internet for the uh what is
it fourth time fifth time if you were
gay for a day
yeah for a day
if you were gay for a day who would you
want to bang wow if you were gay for a
day who would you want to bang i would
say if i was gay for a day i would
probably
i'd want to bang macaulay culkin that's
who i'd want to bang
just a nice
just heroined out macaulay called we got
the same birthday so i feel like we'd
connect on that and it would be more
than just sex with us it'd be emotional
and then and then when he came on my
face i'd go like this
which nfl team would win all white
players are all black players i would
say let's keep it the way it is white
owners black players
what percentage of internet porn do you
think you have seen well that's a good
question that's like what percentage of
the ocean have we explored it's a low
percentage it's a low percentage but i
would say percentage of internet porn do
you think you've seen i would say
10 straight 20 gig
[Laughter]
oh here's this is nice this is a
handwritten one this is this is how you
know you're running out of ideas um
just trying to scribble one on um if you
were serving a life sentence would you
rather be the prisoner everyone fears or
the one nobody knows 100
the prisoner everyone fears tt jerry my
transgender uh godmother of my daughter
100 true tt jerry she was in prison for
20 years she told me if you go to jail
and eventually you will she said you
will need to be you're going to have to
get out there and everyone's got to fear
you because if she told me actually this
thing said if they don't know you
eventually someone's going to come for
you and kill you and make you a sex
slave they got to [ __ ] fear you and
she told me the best thing to do if you
get incarcerated is to immediately go
trans that's what she said so
if you know if i ever if i'm out there
being like i want a sex change it's real
to new me just know i have a case coming
and i i know i'm gonna lose what she
actually did which was [ __ ] nuts she
said there was a really mean guy in her
prison that like she was kind of a
little afraid of but he was a devout
muslim and she said she sucked his dick
in the showers once and had told
everyone that i'm about to suck whatever
his dick his name's dick is and all of
them were kind of in there looking and
she [ __ ] destroyed his credibility
right away so even if he came at her all
his boys and the muslim brother were
like nah because the muslims she said
you cannot be gay if you're a muslim
brother she said you cannot be gay they
are anti-that but they're all gay so if
someone says they're a muslim in jail
i'm like you gay she did blow son of sam
she blew son to sam and
um the guy who did the amityville horror
houses i'm blanking on his name she's
two serial killers
dead ass bro
that's what it is
chrissy chaos if you couldn't get hard
for a year and you find which listen the
blood pressure medication i'm on not you
know it's a little bit like come on
that's why i said i need a [ __ ] slap
from will smith to get it going um
if you couldn't get hard for a year and
you finally got your first boner would
you want to jerk off or [ __ ] a chick
interesting i would still say i probably
wanna i'd jerk off i just wanna jerk off
just the first time jerk off get it
going and then uh yeah to pump a chick i
think so yeah okay
what would your 12-hour crime spree be
during the purge oh my god i would you
know what i do i would just go around
start fingering everyone's [ __ ] just
full figure because i know everyone's
going to be killing everybody and doing
i don't want to do that dude i would
call full just like devious sex crimes
you know not that i want to do that can
we cut this one out
would you rather leave a date with a hot
chick for 10 minutes to take a [ __ ] or
hold it in and hope for the best i would
rather [ __ ] on my date i'd leave her for
10 minutes i'd leave her for dude how
about this one time you ready for this
one time is that the comedy style in new
york city i s beautiful girl took her on
a date to the comedy seller i'm like hey
just wait up here i gotta go downstairs
do my set 15 minutes set easy breezy i
come up she's gone i was like i saw the
waitress i was like where's the girls
with just with she goes oh she left with
aziz i'm
i was like wow this [ __ ]
took my date dude and then i [ __ ]
went home and i i jerked off to masters
of none
about that yeah i talked to him about it
he you know claims he doesn't know he
doesn't yeah he's like oh i don't even
know man i'm sorry i was just doing
something
you know
what would you pick to be the title of
your autobiography what is me because
when you title an autobiography it's got
to be
you know you want to accomplish your
personality who you are my title my uh
autobiography would be
fall in love with men have sex with
women
how many grown men would it take to kill
a grizzly bear with their bare [ __ ]
hands
honestly dude the only grown man i know
that could kill a grizzly bear is tt
jerry and he's a woman i'm not even
trying to be funny i really think like
somebody's job maybe two of the guys
jobs would be to try to de-escalate that
bear and try to jerk it off a little bit
try to make it come so like gets i think
that's the only way you have to get a
little sexual with it start fingering
its ass a little bit you have to because
it's just gonna [ __ ] i think it could
just keep swiping people one after
another that's what i do dude unless the
purge okay would you rather have a dog
die every time you laugh or have there
be a genocide every time you fall in
love i genuinely feel every time i fall
in love there's a genocide i feel like i
feel like i stood literally literally i
remember my high school sweet do you
know something about me i never told you
this this made me think of it
i lost my virginity on 9 11.
the real 9 11 2000 was the first time i
had sex with a woman yes i did yes i did
that you know then that night because it
was like so you know just what up
i forgot it's not a lie i forgot about
it i was 18 years old yeah well no
because i was so upset i thought my mom
died it was like comforting whatever and
she was just like you know like it was
just one thing led to another we had sex
and then i felt guilty about having sex
with her on that and then i from like
september 12th to whenever we declared
war in iraq i didn't jerk off
so sure do you jerk off on 9 11 now no i
won't do it now now it's very difficult
no it's very i get drunk and do comedy
check out my 911 story
she was like you want this al qaeda
[ __ ]
let's see if you could be the patron
saint of something what would it be the
booster no um
dr faunchi
what doc faucy gave me aids is the name
of my autobiography um i honestly
parallel parking i literally will
parallel park the [ __ ] out of any car
you give me and i could do it right left
whatever vehicle whatever country
whatever side of the road step up to me
if there's a parallel parking
competition i'm in it and i'm the number
one seed 100
if you came across a glory hole would
you put your dick in it you mean again
um
yes a hundred percent i would why who
wouldn't put their dick in a glory hole
in that situation i mean just put your
dick in it doesn't matter i feel like
putting your dick in something and you
don't know what you're what if there's a
[ __ ] dog on the other side there eat
your dick there's many different ways to
come my friend
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon